Hôm qua thường của gặp thủ tụng đường Friedrich Muzz cả nhà trắng
Tổng mì đưa nân trăm chỉ chỉ tế bằng nhà
Tư chối cho Mỹ sử dụng gặp thương quan
Phục vô trên sĩ cân công y ra
và không tăng chỉ tư quốc phòng thử dụng của nó tôi
Ông những mạnh sẽ khách mọi thở thận thương mại với mà truyền nếu cần
Đồng thời tổng thống trang của mày tỏ bắt bình về ăn
Lên quan đến việc nâng ngày từ chú tham gia các cuộc khôn kết
Mặc dù vẫn hú trộng hả động phòng thuộc khu bực
Truy đó, Mỹ về xưa ra phát động chính xị không kết và y ra nửa
Tư này hai mày tăng thân hay
Nhâm vào các cơ quan tình báo của phòng và quân chức khách tham y ra nửa
Phà nước lại, tư hiệt ra nửa phóng tư lừa vô hả vê nguyên bấy xưa ra
Phụng có cân của Mỹ cho khu bực
Lê thiệt hại nhiều biê hạ tân và thương thông
Chú bó cạnh này các đồng ý chú ông như pháp đức ăn
Hình thần định sẵn sàng bảo vệ lưỡi tại ngủ vệ
Nhưng dưới hạm thăm ra chức tế và cơ đợt tân công
Tần thông đông đông đông chăm nhớ mạnh rằng phà nước phía ước tác của anh và tế bất nhà đã làm cảm chờ chính xịt
Và làm phức tàm kính hòa quân sự của Mỹ